peaceful rallies underway across the
country to commemorate juneteenth the
official end of slavery in the united
states
it comes as president trump gears up for
a major relaunch of his campaign with a
huge rally tomorrow night in tulsa
oklahoma
it's his first since the pandemic
started supporters lining up
all week and his campaign says 1 million
people have rsvp'd
the city's mayor declaring a civil
emergency over fears of violent protests
and rioting
president trump responding with a stern
warning to quote
agitators looters and low lives
saying illegal behavior will not be
tolerated critics of the rally are
of course out in full force claiming the
event poses a huge coronavirus risk
but the trump campaign is taking
precautions and the governor of oklahoma
says
the event will be safe we've got to
learn to deal with this we've got to
learn to be
safe take precautions but we've got to
learn to also live our lives
and uh we feel like it's uh the right
time to
uh start reopening and so we're excited
about the president coming
uh and again like like they said before
there's been over a million requests for
for tickets and so i think it just shows
that america's ready to start getting
back to normal
uh judge jeanine how dare these low
lives come into tosa oklahoma and try to
disrupt the peaceful rally
well you you know what's interesting
about all of this is that you know
there's so much concern
about what about coven and how it's
going to impact people
look the trump campaign is going above
and beyond what they need to do
they're taking temperatures they're
giving mass they're giving people gloves
uh and oklahoma if you recall was one of
the first states to
to open after the pandemic the only
problem seems to be that the
the individuals coming in to make
trouble and the president has made it
very clear what he intends to do
uh that they're not going to be treated
the way that the the protesters or
rioters were treated in
minneapolis and in seattle and in new
york city
so i think the dichotomy is going to be
clear
on the resistance to this particular
rally
but the rally is exactly what donald
trump needs right now
it's where he gets his confidence it's
where the people feel his energy
and i think it's going to be a very
positive thing and hopefully it will be
peaceful
his events are it's just a question of
what the outsiders want to do
and the drama and trauma that they want
to create
craig so oklahoma they're in phase three
that's the last phase i mean you can uh
you can go eat at a restaurant you can
get a massage if you want to gut felt
i mean there's no restrictions on mass
gatherings at all
so it looks like oklahoma has things
under control right now
well personally i like to get a meal and
a massage at the same time
saves uh saves a lot of time in my day
uh anyway it's interesting because i
mean
obviously we've been talking about how
the media portrays uh
these rallies versus protests they
weren't too con concerned about
what they were doing to protect
themselves in the protests and now with
this it's like everybody's evil
it it just it speaks to the fact that
never has a leader
stirred such a panic and so much bile
from the establishment media
and what it's telling you is that trump
is not a threat to you he's not a threat
to the people
he's a threat to establishment media
he's essentially the hell's angels
uh the 1970s oakland raiders uh
the magnificent seven and harry callahan
all wrapped into one
and he scares the media so much that
they have to demonize him in every
single way uh looking back when trump
said
fake news is the enemy of the people it
might have been the most meaningful
statement since tear down the wall
i know that's going to upset a lot of
people but we are now the country is now
seeing what he knew that the media is
manipulating us
and they're trying to manipulate us to
so that we hate each other
because as long as we fight each other
if it's black versus white male versus
female
the media is able to stay in power
because once we come together
they're out of business so it's in their
best interest to keep us
at our throats
that's a great point let's go to one of
the members of the hell's angels dana
perrino
dana um to greg's point about the threat
that president trump poses right um
you mentioned the other day that i think
it was you that the build up to this
rally has really been spectacular
um what do you expect to see on saturday
night because i know you'll be watching
our coverage on fox news i
never miss saturday night lineup um so
yeah yeah i think it was yesterday i
said it was like the build-up to the
super bowl
um i think there's a lot of pent-up
demand americans don't have any sports
to watch
so they're ready for this the great
sporting event
of america which is our elections every
four years
which actually never really end the
campaigns keep going
but i do i do think that even though the
official start to the campaign was even
a year ago
that it does feel like now tomorrow
night you're going to have
an event where they're familiar to us um
and people enjoy watching them obviously
we know that we know that people like to
go to them
um i thought it was interesting that the
biting campaign
decided to do a counter programming so
they said okay we'll see
your rally with a million people
requesting tickets and raise you
a zoom conference call and the dichotomy
there
is going to be super stark across the
board
now one of the things that's happening
is that president trump is not only
energizing his voters
he's energizing voters who want to vote
against him
so going forward as we kick off this
election season i think in full that's
what i see tomorrow night as
we'll have to see how the biden campaign
can try to match this
yeah that's interesting juan what do you
think about that
how does the biden campaign see these
rallies put the
coronavirus stuff aside i mean how do
they view this
uh the political opposition that holds
these massive rallies and really get a
lot of traction from
uh i i can't speak for the campaign i
can tell you how i see them jesse i
think they are
you know a lot like a rock concert or uh
you know a wrestling event or something
come to town i mean i think that's why
brad pascal
picked tulsa in that part of oklahoma
the president
wanted i think plus 36 or something he's
a big
it's a red state and so he should be
able to get a lot of folks out
i don't think that it necessarily
indicates much about the state of the
campaign the polls fox polls has biden
up by 12.
but my concern today is about this tweet
i mean anarchists looters low-life jesse
i mean what is going on the president of
the united states
seems to lack a fundamental
understanding of the right of americans
to protest
that's that's like motherhood and apple
pie it's a first
amendment it's not a latter amendment
it's the very
first amendment that you have the right
to get out there
and be heard by your political
leadership in this country
and that to demean them and to degrade
them
i just don't understand it
overwhelmingly peaceful
not even close like 90 something percent
peaceful
so to me what he does i guess he can
stir up the basement let's just let's
just conversations
[Applause]
but as soon as you cross the line into
being a looter
and an arsonist it's time to put you in
cuffs and drag you down
to the station okay nobody the president
was talking
is not what's going on tolerate that
judge that's not
what that kind of energy in this country
has missed
that's what he was talking about you
have to give me this nonsense
minneapolis that is not true
but i mean that's not again it is this
is the this is from the president
hey everybody hey everybody it was
peaceful it was peaceful what happened
in my neighborhood
it really didn't happen when they
destroyed and looted every
every store in my neighborhood that
didn't happen minneapolis didn't happen
atlanta did when they burned wendy's
that didn't happen according to juan
none of this scene it was all a dream
a beautiful dream thank you for
respecting
i can see that you have nightmares it
ain't happening but i
i can see you have nightmares i think
you're afraid of something you're in
denial yeah
you're wrong you're lying to him by the
way it's very
we have live coverage for president
trump's rally in tulsa tomorrow
starting with you know what's
comfortable waters world 8 p.m
we're gonna have the rally live and
we'll be reacting to it then at nine
judge jeanine comes on so catch her and
then greg
has a big show at 10. greg what do you
have planned at 10
oh i've got everything i got balloons
i've got animals
i've got dagon mcdowell charlie hurt we
are going to have pie eating contests
and just a carnival atmosphere it'll be
like a wrestling event
okay we'll make sure we watch